do you have any framework for the
meaning of life any symbol system yeah
any tradition that speaks to you
i have
i have two
ideas that
have sung a song in my heart so yeah
what do i know about the meaning of life
but like i could tell you about the deep
songs in my heart you hit him
one
and and the the
i came at them because i'm just like
very you can probably tell i like start
from the abstract on down stars down to
soil instead of soil up to stars but i
could start from the sars down to the
soil but
you know i have these two ideas that i'm
like fighting for in my public life
which are democracy and solidarity
but there's like a core concrete thing
inside of each of those so what's the
thing inside of democracy the thing is
that democracy in my in my heart is like
creativity there's some spiritual thing
about the fact that the world presents
us with something and we come up with
something else
um and there's this amazing philosopher
roberto hunger who says there's more in
us
in each of us individually he has these
grand quotes there is more in us in each
of us individually and in all of us
collectively than there ever is in the
world
and the act of creation is the act of
turning the tables on the world the
world gives you a script it tries to
code a machine in your head but inside
your head is also an anti-machine called
the imagination this is all this is the
whole quote
no no i stopped the quote and then just
did summaries after that
an anti-machine called the imagination
where the new is created and i just
think there's there's something amazing
there's something really special so
that's him like putting words in a thing
i just felt deeper than words which is
i just love the idea that people have
ideas and i just love it i think
everybody has ideas and what i say the
project of democracy is the project
democracy is society admitting that
everyone has ideas everyone can
co-create our shared world and so i
really believe in the like spiritual
project of respecting the gifts that you
were given as your ideas and oh my gosh
i've been given a gift from the spirit
world it's an idea or it's a thing and
now i if i find it to be authentic and
true i have to do the labor of bringing
it into the world by painting the
painting you know yeah the idea comes to
you and if you say no it'll go to
somewhere yeah go to someone and it's
like oh gosh and then and i have to
carry this yes and and then you do the
work of that and then the project in
society is the project of saying
all the people no matter their
background no matter where they're from
no matter where they are they have the
the spirit realm doesn't care
like who they are in all the structures
of our world the ideas will come to them
too so that's one so that's democracy
solidarity
is um
the core thing of that is like the
unprofound thing of love it's that if if
if the creation stuff is we want to help
everyone achieve their dreams or realize
their dreams this is about seeing each
other's dreams as our own
it's like the martin luther king stuff
of we're all bound in a in a in a single
garment of humanity we're all trying the
catholic stuff of uh
of i love this quote from father james f
keenan i have like my little hero
intellectual heroes of all the different
parts of it that have put words and
whatever what i felt he said mercy
is the willingness to enter into the
chaos of others
and he's like that's what god did with
jesus is he said oh i'm in comfort
there's a lot of chaos down there i'm
gonna the the message of christianity is
god
um entered into the chaos of humanity
and what we have to do what usually our
sin is is not like i drank when i said i
want drink or something our sin is the
failure to bother to love and love is
willingness to enter into the chaos of
others oh i have comfort but someone's
having a really chaotic thing over there
i'm gonna jump in i'm gonna jump in like
god jumped into us you know and not that
we're god but that like we'll act as as
as he did and and
in doing that in caring and extending
mercy to each other the catholics have
this like phrase the works of mercy
where they said okay if you don't know
what we mean by that i'm gonna lay it
out there
feed feed the hungry give drink to the
thirsty you know um uh clothe the naked
visit the imprisoned visit the sick you
know bury the dead um
uh what you do in caring for each other
in being merciful to each other is you
weave us all together you start
re-knitting the stuff that you repair
the breach you bridge the divides you
bring the outside in and the inside out
you know and um
and weave together the garment again so
so that's the work of solidarity and so
those are my those are my two was that
too what a stupid answer my word my
worry was
what are you crazy
it's fantastic oh yeah
[Music]